welcome to oh my god that's a sofa I
don't remember the cruel ways of
something I don't remember
I actually done see started playing and
I found out a secret so I tried putting
it back and be like oh wow that's
totally a lot of stuff here oh my god I
can't believe I didn't think of that
haha anyway we have the land and I feel
so much better alright what do we get
hey lad madam drugs I mean light night
Adam nah that wouldn't be awesome no
actually wouldn't be awesome that I
think right I was gonna say it wouldn't
be awesome if there was a drug Cole at
nighttime but there already is one it's
called pot [ __ ] why didn't you break
laughter yeah let's see a problem pot
huh you tell me you tell me special what
seriously what did you buy okay me with
ah there we go
that's what I'm oh no period on the
floor that's not good barrel hey that's
a lot of butts hey hey secrets pick up
hey you are not coming with me I know
your partner's answer I don't trust pots
you can never trust anything
hey is that ketchup ha ha ha that's
awesome I always want to catch oh that
explains all this it's obviously cat
chips can you see it can you see it flat
all right I'm glad this is explained
I was quite curious all right how are
you doing brush I don't trust any of you
yeah
blowing a lot of [ __ ] today a small hint
for you I guess you have a problem with
the second alright
well you inspected the floor thoroughly
you will find the key look that's a
difficult one I told it nailed it
I'm sorry you will find the key if I
inspect the floor well maybe it's in the
period maybe it's beneath it mr. Sher
what are you doing petty doctor I'm
sorry but you're sure I respect you more
than okay I'm sorry I'm sorry but yeah
why are you damn pity I have matched up
where's that oh I know where this I know
it is I saw I saw this no I thought it
was gonna be on them get out of my way
get out I'm looking for have you seen it
all right mr. Sher mr. Shep stop stop
this is a mess stop it stop are you
serious where's the key
maybe sticking me maybe it's in the
floor maybe the floor okay that's pity
Jesus guys I can't believe you didn't
see me you always ignore me
Jesus guys look you nailed it Kevin you
don't even do anything I'm glad you're
here spawning cos I can't find the
[ __ ] that's obvious meaning it's
obvious it's so freakin obvious hey
where is that [ __ ] King so she
deployed thirdly maybe it needs
something else and I think cuz I thought
it meant like don't search the guy come
on wasted you having problems right I'll
[ __ ] you come here make sure we are
emptying this room
Oh mr. shirt now pretty down Jarrett
damn I just went hang out with my friend
I don't care you can't even call wait
hip forget something maybe no we don't
get [ __ ] paint got you maybe he's
tricking me why am I wasting my land
that's another we will never find the
answer for all right mr. Jericho I don't
trust this I said ketchup in amnesia I
don't I
I'll never know what is this [ __ ] key
tell me I don't have time for this they
give you some other clue than just on
the [ __ ] floor
I'd much appreciate it I can't see [ __ ]
so yeah thanks for the tip bruh search
the floor thirdly pity okay
such here I'm sorry there may be
searched under here
all right not behind there why am I
wasting my life and we'll never know lab
bugs
I think I needed sheep because I can't
find this [ __ ] key I just love having
to look up some German guy Pralay
amnesia I mean a combination in a higher
pitch near me hamish neighbor time to
karma and affirmation become the
foundation to me I'm sure that's my
impression on what's the name of this
[ __ ] mod the crew all right okay this
is awkward
oh wow this is a mess mr. Jack get out
of here stop gang bowels and I just hear
smooth this is [ __ ] car there we go
I found it
oh my god they're [ __ ] everywhere all
right mr. Ciampa oh my god oh oh my oh
my lord everywhere hey mr. Phan already
you and nearly forgot about me Jesus
Christ payday I am so [ __ ]
disappointed oh you're always
disappointed I'm sorry Stephane yeah
whatever
alright try to light your ways don't
waste it all trying not to die dr. Jones
Jones calling Michael Jones dr. Jones
that dude don't get up now who's the
next sounds fine get up now dr. Jones
Jones calling dr. Jones dr. Jones dr.
Jones get up now get up now
baa what ba you ha ha sorry ok let's
continue
nice nice ringing there smiley thank you
very much I am very good with my height
Zavala
Jesus guys all right motor kitchen it's
okay Duffy don't miss Cal what was that
hey a crowbar hello come by
hey Ginny Margaret and I always forget
to use hey don't try to hide from me
than their backs okay we're sure first
that's the one looks scary let's try
this one first okay you first of all as
always this guy's a [ __ ]
try to light your way but don't waste
our hey what is this
someone did something that what I didn't
even know it happened where's Savannah
Savannah ready to go now huh huh where
did he go down the toilet no nah it's a
mess to find everything toilet I knew it
I don't even know what happened I just
kind of died insane holy [ __ ]
so fun where is it's far away you go
buddy oh that's cozy
no what the hell just happened it's more
ketchup I don't understand this mother
where's the share town more heaven I'm
sorry Pete I can't explain to you it
wouldn't be a good cousin story either
way
how does chair mode that's all I do but
you never share much sorry
hey salariki
it's dry and then go
alright good you finally keep you down
I'm happy for you I'm so happy why do we
get a [ __ ] alright Ken gun ha ha you
thought you were finished huh
beside you we're finished no you're not
no you're not pity you never fit you
will never finish this but never are you
against me mister yeah I'm sorry but I'm
just trying to be again
ha ha you did a pity oh no no I don't
want to go that scary pity I was just
kidding this Christ the second dead rice
and stuff I hate dead rats look at me
I'm better I grew up in the fine ah I'm
in sharing what Pete don't touch me ok
you go first missus yeah I like you I
will you CSS you hey I'm not a frickin
sheer pity Jesus Christ I know as much
okay place I don't trust any one of
y'all brah stop it you're not funny
you're not funny
none of you are funny you're boring
people if I had a teleport thingy I
would not just run around and I guess
you I wouldn't run cuz I would teleport
but I just wouldn't yeah yeah I can't
even talk I just want to tell apart in
people's faces that's what I'm trying to
say and you can't hear me cuz you have
no head how about dad how about dad I
was gonna read this now block the door
I'm gonna bad private in the back dr.
Jones Jones it's calling dr. Gellin dr.
Jones dr. don't take mr. Gein up now get
up there you're not as good as Stephano
at singing I must give you the I ride I
talk of my PT I was at an American Idol
watch
I nearly want I came second last after
that freaking crazy
yeah kept saying how I don't even know
candy candy candy we will cooperate the
imposition sweets you're not so unusable
after all Thank You Petey okay there's
about why I'm in down here
I can go here am I supposed to go here
hold a better question I have not going
down this to share like that hey I'm
glad you came pity I'm out
I don't climb walls I'm not spider out
Hey all right
spider share spied your hair - whatever
a spider here and swing from share no
yeah she can he's just walking in
circles that's fantastic Wow okay more
barrels I'm not allowed to scream
barrels too loud kisi bro let's get
scared barrels why are you carrying a
box man why are you going to pop hey you
try to hide a lot none from me barrel
you try to hide you lie tonight now give
me my drugs light battle Jesus Christ
let's keep on trying all right can I
cooperate can I help you go up there and
get the stuff thank you
alright coming out the Legion can I read
this one pt right sure congratulations
you came fire but I don't trust anything
down here and prepared some fat for you
dr. Jones you want some bread miss jeren
sure sure molded Fred why not what did
you say mr. Sherr nothing Hey I would
actually something about you being
retired chair mode activate whoop that
was a late reaction sorry but I'm a
share I can't always be on top I can't
help you there
the way the [ __ ] are we gonna why do we
use the crowbar it's gotta be somewhere
I don't know bTW I'm trying I really are
now oh that makes me [ __ ] don't have a
cute home I just picked up a hell out of
Clyde and I don't even know one more
maybe here that the sheep again I don't
want the Sheep again holy [ __ ] only
shares I thought you're doing you're
still standing that these guys why don't
you go tell apart somewhere I'll never
understand what about this place nope it
does not weigh hey Jennifer looking good
thank you pity all right what are you
doing here random barrel get out of here
get the fudge Wow Wow barrels [ __ ] wait
there's there's something behind here no
there's got to be a [ __ ] phone keep
me down me alright mr. sheriff since I
don't really know what to do I think I'm
gonna end this episode here I hope you
bros enjoyed if you did be sure to make
mr. chair I don't know be sure to make
pretty happy and like favorite and
subscribe and he'll see you tomorrow
alright here comes my cheer mode cheer
mode activate totally fail there alright
[Music]
Jason Jason taste it taste it taste it
taste it taste it taste it taste it
taste it taste it - dad